moi je pense que n'importe qui peut
l'ouvrir hein non enfin bon mais tout
tout est arraché là tout est arraché
Jean-Gabriel Fournier est un client
désabusé depuis l'année dernière cet
inimentin subit des interruptions de
connexion régulière lié à la fibre
optique assuré aujourd'hui par
l'opérateur SFR via sa filiale XP fibre
l'infrastructure subit fréquemment des
pannes longues tout comme cet habitant
des abonnés ont déposé plus de 170
plaintes auprès de la commune entre 2020
et 2023 un sentiment d'impuissance face
au service clients des fournisseurs Free
Orange T ou SFR chacun se rejette la
responsabilité et facture malgré tout
les utilisateurs on je avec un voyant
qui s'éteint tout de suite je fonce à
l'armoire et généralement je vois un
technicien alors le technicien c'est pas
des gens ni NFR ni d'orange c'est des
sous-traitants donc et là ah ben vous
savez moi on me demande de brancher 5
personnes j'ai que qu quatre
emplacements ben j'en ai branche un au
hasard et j'en mets un pourquoi parce
que dès qu'ils sont dès qu' a une
connexion tout de suite ils sont tarifé
bien que le réseau ne dépende pas de la
commune Montini le bretonne se mobilise
pour palier le vandalisme elle décide
d'installer en 2022 des antivols sur la
dizaine d'armoires les plus touchées
pour y accéder le technicien est
contraint de venir récupérer la clé
auprès de la police municipale mais
aujourd'hui plus de 50 cadenas ont été
fracturés nous savons que nous avons
plein de salariés par exemple qui sont
en télétravail qui ont besoin de pouvoir
travailler depuis chez eux nous avons
énormément de familles d'enfants qui ont
besoin d'avoir un accès à Internet et
donc il est absolument inimaginable et
intolérable aujourd'hui en 2024 l'année
olympique nous n'ayons pas de solution
et que nous ayons un opérateur qui soit
en incapacité de répondre à tous ces
problèmes qui sont posés sur la vie une
inquiétude grandissante pour la commune
et ses administrés le réseau ADSL
devrait disparaître à partir de 2025 au
profit de la fibre optique de quoi
laisser craindre des difficultés
supplémentaires pour les abonnés si
aucune réponse n'est apportée